foreign
welcome everybody to another of my
storytelling with Sadler this time I'm
going to be talking about this great
short story by Stephen Vincent Benet
called the king of the cats it's one
that I have loved since I was a kid I
don't remember exactly when I first read
it it was in an anthology and some of
you may be familiar with these uh Alfred
Hitchcock Presents anthologies my uncle
Hubert I've talked about this in other
videos every Christmas for about five or
six years he would get me one of these
books Haunted House full Sinister spies
you know Tales of Terror and suspense
and they would have all these great
anthologies
um of uh wonderful stories that weren't
actually so much just for children but
could we appreciate by adults and this
is one of those that I particularly
liked as a
and I've gone back to it a number of
times sometimes just in
reading it and uh I've really enjoyed it
over the course of my life so I'm going
to read this story to you you can feel
free to comment whatever you want in the
live chat and then after I'm done I'll
uh address the comments and probably
tell you a little bit more about what I
find particularly cool and compelling
about this short story so with no
further Ado let's get started the king
of the cats by Stephen Vincent Benet
but my dear said Mr culverin with a tiny
gasp you can't actually mean a tail
Mrs Dingle not an impressively exactly
I've seen him twice Paris of course and
then a command appearance at Rome we
were in the Royal box he conducted my
clear you've never heard such effects
from an orchestra and my dear she
hesitated slightly he conducted with it
how perfectly fascinatingly too horrid
for Words said Mrs Culver in in a dazed
but greedy voice we must have him to
dinner as soon as he comes over he is
coming over isn't he
the 12th said Mrs Dingle with a gleam In
Her Eyes the new symphony people have
asked him to be guest conductor for
three special concerts I do hope you can
dine with us some night while he's here
he'll be very busy of course but he's
promised to give us what time he can
spare
oh thank you dear said Mrs culverland
abstractedly her last raid upon Mrs
dingle's pet British novelist still
fresh in her mind you're always so
delightfully hospitable but you mustn't
wear yourself out the rest of us must do
our part I know Henry and myself would
be only too glad to that that's very
sweet of you darling Mrs Dingle also
remembered the larceny of the British
novelist but we're going to give
Monsieur Tebow sweet name isn't it they
say he's descended from the tabalt in
Romeo and Juliet and that's why he
doesn't like Shakespeare we're going to
give Monsieur tibol the simplest sort of
time a little reception after his first
concert perhaps he hates she looked
around the table large mixed parties and
then of course with his little
idiosyncrasy she coughed delicately it
makes him feel a little trifle shy with
strangers
but I don't understand yet Aunt Emily
said Tommy Brooks Mrs dingle's nephew do
you really mean this Tebow Bozo has a
tail like a monkey and everything
Tommy dear said Mrs Culver at Culver
uncrushingly in the first place the Seer
Tipo is not a bozo he has a very
distinguished musician the finest
conductor in Europe and in the second
place
he has Mrs Dingle was firm he has a tail
he conducts with it oh but honestly said
Tommy his ear is pinking I mean of
course if you say so Aunt Emily I'm sure
he has but still it sounds pretty steep
if you know what I mean how about it
Professor tato Professor tato cleared
his throat he put his fingertips
together cautiously I shall be very
anxious to see this Monsieur tibo for
myself I have never observed genuine
specimen of homo cudatus so I should be
inclined to doubt and yet in the Middle
Ages for instance the belief in men or
Terror Tales where with caudal
appendages of some sort was widespread
and as we can gather well founded
as late as the 18th century a Dutch C
Captain with some character for veracity
recounts the discovery of such a pair of
creatures on the island of Formosa they
were in a low state of civilization I
believe but the appendages in question
were quite distinct and in 1860 the
group of the Excursion comes to have
treated no less than three African
natives with short
though his testimony rests upon
unsupported word after all the thing is
not impossible though doubtless unusual
web feat rudimentary gills these occur
with some frequency
the appendix we have with us always the
chain of our descent from the ape-like
form is by no means complete for that
matter he beamed around the table what
we can call the last few vertebrae of
the normal spine but the beginnings of a
concealed and rudimentary tale oh yes
yes it's possible quite that in an
extraordinary case a reversion to type a
survival though of course I Told You So
said Mrs Dingle triumphantly isn't it
fascinating isn't it princess
the princess vivera canarda's eyes Blew
as a field of Larkspur fathomless as the
center of Heaven rested for a moment on
Mrs dingle's excited countenance
very fascinating she said in a voice
like stroked golden velvet I should like
I should like very much to meet this
Monsieur Tebow
well I hope he breaks his neck said
Tommy Brooks under his breath but nobody
paid much attention to Tommy
nevertheless
as the time for Mr T boa's arrival in
these states grew near and nearer people
in general began to wonder whether the
princess had spoken quite truthfully for
there was no doubt of the fact that up
till then she'd been the unique
sensation of the season and you know
what social lions and lionesses are it
was if you remember a Siamese season and
genuine Siamese were quite as much of a
premium as Russian accents had been in
the quaint old days when the show Suri
was a novelty the Siamese Art Theater
imported at terrific expense was playing
to pack houses
an Epic Novel of Siamese Farm life and
19 closely printed volumes had just been
awarded the Nobel Prize prominent pet
and Newt dealers reported no cessation
in the appalling demand for Siamese cats
and on the crest of this wave of
interest and things Siamese the princess
vivra canarda poised with the elegant
nonchalance of the Hawaiian water baby
upon its surfboard she was indispensable
she was incomparable she was everywhere
youthful enormously wealthy Allied on
one hand to the royal family of Siam and
on the other to the Cabots and yet with
the first 18 of her 21 years shrouded
from speculation in a golden zone of
mystery the mingling of races in heard
produced an exotic Beauty as
distinguished as it was strange she
moved with feline effortless Grace and
her skin was if it had just just been
gently powdered with tiny grains of the
purest gold yet the blueness of her eyes
is that just a trifle slantingly was as
pure and startling as the sea on the
rocks of Maine her brown hair fell to
her knees she hadn't been ordered
extraordinary sums by the master Barbers
protective Association to have it
shingled so straight as a waterfall
tumbling over brown rocks it had a vague
perfume of sandalwood and suede spices
and held tints of rust and the sun she
did not talk very much but then she did
not have to
her voice had an odd small melodiousness
huskiness that haunted the mind
she lived alone and was reputed to be
very lazy at least it was known she
slept during most of the day but at
night she bloomed like a Moon Flower and
a depth came into her eyes it was no
wonder that Tommy Brooks fell in love
with her the Wonder was that she let him
there was nothing exotic or
distinguished about Tommy he was just
one of those pleasant normal young men
who seemed to carry on the bond business
by reading the newspapers in the
University Club during most of the day
and can always be relied upon at night
to fill in an unexpected hole in a
dinner party
it is true that the princess could
hardly be said to do more than tolerate
any of her suitors no one had ever seen
those aloofly arrogant eyes enliven at
the entrance of any male but she seemed
to be able to tolerate Tommy a little
bit more than the rest and that young
man's infatuated Daydreams were
beginning to be beset by smart
solitaires and imaginary apartments on
Park Avenue when the famous Mr tibo
conducted his first concert at Carnegie
Hall
oh
Tommy Brooks sat beside the princess
the eyes he turned upon her were eyes of
longing and love but her face was
impassive as a mask and the only remark
she made during the preliminary
bustlings was that there seemed to be a
number of people in the audience but
Tommy was relieved if anything to find
her even a little more aloof than usual
forever since Mr cauldron's Mrs Culver's
dinner party a vague disquiet as to the
possible impression which this Tebow
creature might make upon her had been
growing in his mind it shows his
devotion that he was present at all
to a man whose simple princetonian
nature found in Just a Little Love a
Little Kiss the quintessence of musical
art the average Symphony was a positive
torture and he looked forward to the
evenings program itself with a grim
Brave smile
said Mrs Dingle breathlessly he's coming
it seemed to the startled Tommy as if he
were suddenly back in the trenches under
a heavy barrage as Monsieur tibol made
his entrance to a perfect bombardment of
applause
then the enthusiastic noise was sliced
off in the middle and a gasp took its
place a vast windy size if every person
in that multitude had suddenly said ah
for the papers had not lied about him
the tale was there
they called him theatric but how well he
understood the uses of theatricalism
dressed in the UN unrelieved black from
head to foot the black dress shirt had
been a special token of Mussolini's
esteem he did not walk on he strolled
leisurely easily aloofly the famous tale
curled nonchalantly about one wrist a
Suave black panther lounging through a
summer garden with that little
mysterious weave of the head that
Panthers have when they pad Behind Bars
the glittering darkness of his eyes
unmoved by any surprise or Elation he
nodded twice in Regal acknowledgment as
the Clapping reached an apogee of frenzy
to Tommy there was something dreadfully
reminiscent of the princess in the way
he nodded then he turned to his
orchestra
a second and louder gasp went up from
the audience at this point for as he
turned the tip of that incredible tail
twined with dainty carelessness into
some hidden Pocket and produced a black
baton Tommy did not even notice he was
looking at the princess instead
should not bother to clap at first but
now he'd never seen her move like this
never she was not applauding her hands
were clenched in her lap but her whole
body was rigid rigid as a steel bar and
the blue flowers of her eyes were bent
on the figure of monsieur tibo in a
terrible concentration the pose of her
entire figure was so still and intense
that for an instant Tommy had the
lunatic idea that any moment she might
lean from her Leap from her seat beside
him as lightly as a moth and land with
no sound at Miss Monsieur Tebow's side
to yes to rub her proud head against his
coat in worship
even Mrs Dingle would notice in a moment
princess he said in a horrified whisper
princess
slowly the tenseness of her body relaxed
her eyes veiled again she grew calm
yes Tommy she said in her usual voice
but there was still something about her
nothing oh hang he's starting said Tommy
as Monsieur tiboa's hands Loosely
clasped before him turned and faced the
audience his eyes dropped his tail
switched once impressively and then gave
three preliminary taps with his baton on
the floor
seldom has glukes Overture to ifajany
and Alice receive such an ovation but it
was not until the eighth Symphony that
the hysteria of the audience reached its
climax never before had the new symphony
played so superbly and certainly never
before had it been LED with such genius
three prominent conductors in the
audience were sobbing with the
despairing admiration of envious
children towards the close and one at
least Was Heard to offer wildly ten
thousand dollars to a well-known facial
surgeon there present for a shred of
evidence that Tales of some variety
could by any stretch of science be
grafted on a normally decoutative form
there was no doubt about it no mortal
hand and arm be they ever so dexterous
could combine the delicate Elan and
Powerful Grace displayed in every
gesture of Monsieur tea Bo's tale a
sable staff it dominated the brasses
like a flicker of black lightning and
ebony elusive whip it drew the last
Exquisite breath of Melody from the
woodwinds and ruled the stormy strings
like a magician's Rod
mrtibo bow bowed and bowed again Roar
after Roar of frenzied admiration shook
the hall to its foundations and when he
finally staggered exhausted from the
platform the president of the Wednesday
Sonata Club was only restrained from by
force from flinging her ninety thousand
dollar String of Pearls after him in an
excess of aesthetic appreciation New
York had come and seen and New York was
conquered
Mrs Dingle was immediately besieged by
reporters and Tommy Brooks look forward
to the little party at which he was to
meet the new hero of the hour with
feelings only a little less lugubrious
than those that would have come to him
just before taking his seat in the
electric chair
the meeting between his princess and
mrtibol was worse and better than he
expected because better because after
all they did not say much to each other
and worse because it seemed to him that
somehow some Curious kinship of mine
between them made words unnecessary they
were certainly the most distinguished
looking couple in the room as he bent
over her hand so darlingly foreign both
of them and yet so different babbled Mrs
Dingle but Tommy couldn't agree
they were different yes the dark life
stranger with the bizarre appendage
talked carelessly in his pocket and the
blue-eyed brown-haired girl but that
difference only accentuated what they
had in common something in the way they
moved in the suavity of their gestures
in the set of their eyes something
deeper even than race he tried to puzzle
it out then looking around at the others
he had a flash of Revelation
it was as if the couple were foreign
indeed not only to New York but to all
common Humanities if they were polite
guests from a different star
Tommy did not have a very happy evening
on the whole but his mind worked slowly
and it was not until much later that the
Mad suspicion came on him in full force
perhaps he's not to be blamed for his
lack of immediate comprehension the next
few weeks were weeks of the withered
misery it was not that the princess's
attitude towards him had changed she was
just as tolerant of him as before but
sir tibol was always there he had a
faculty of appearing as out of thin air
he walked for all of his height as
lightly as his butterfly as a butterfly
and Tommy grew to hate that faintest
shuffle on the carpet that announced his
presence
and then hang it all the man was so
smooth so infernally unruffably smooth
he was never out of temper never
embarrassed he treated Tommy with the
extreme of urbanity and yet his eyes
mocked deep down and Tommy could do
nothing and gradually the princess
became more and more drawn to this
Stranger in a soundless communion that
found little need for speech and that
too Tommy saw and hated and that too he
could not mend he began to be haunted
not only by Monsieur Tebow in the flesh
but by Monsieur Tebow and the spirit he
slept badly and when he slept he dreamed
of Monsieur tibo a man no longer but a
shadow A specter the limber ghost of an
animal whose words came purringly
between sharp little pointed teeth
there was certainly something odd about
the whole shape of the fellow his fluid
ease the mold of his head even the cut
of his fingernails
but just what it was escaped Tommy's
intensis
cogitation and when he did put his
finger on it at length at first he
refused to believe
a pair of petty incidents decided him
finally against all reason
he'd gone to Mrs dingles one winter
afternoon hoping to find the princess
she was out with his aunt but she was
expected back for tea and he wandered
idly into the library to wait
he was just about to switch on the
lights for the library was always dark
even in summer when he heard a sound of
light breathing that seemed to come from
the leather couch in the corner he
approached it cautiously and dimly made
out the form of Monsieur tibo curled up
on the couch peacefully asleep
the sight annoyed Tommy so that he swore
under his breath and was back near the
door on his way out when the feeling we
all know and hate the feeling that eyes
we cannot see are watching Arrested him
he turned back
had not moved a muscle of his body to
all appearance but his eyes were open
now and those eyes were black and human
no longer they were Green Tommy could
have sworn it and he could have sworn
that they had no bottom and gleamed like
emeralds in the dark it only lasted a
moment for Tommy pressed the light
button automatically and there was
Missouri bow his normal self yawning a
little but urbanly apologetic but it
gave Tommy time to think
nor did what happened to trifle later
increase his peace of mind they had lit
a fire and were talking in front of it
by now Tommy hated Monsieur Tebow so
thoroughly that he felt the odd yearning
uh for his company that often occurs in
such cases Monsieur Tebow is telling
some anecdote and Tommy was hating him
worse than ever for Basking with such
obvious enjoyment In the Heat of the
flames and the Ripple of his own voice
then they heard the street door open and
monsters jumped up and jumped and caught
one sock on the sharp corner of the
brass fire Rail and tore it open in a
jagged flap Tommy looked down
mechanically at the terror a seconds
glance but enough
for Mr Tebow for the first time in
Tommy's experience lost his temper
completely he swore violently in some
spitting foreign tongue his face
distorted suddenly he clasped his hand
over the sock then glaring furiously at
Tommy he fairly sprang from the room and
Tommy could hear him scaling the stairs
in Long agile bounds
Tommy sank into a chair careless for
once so the fact that it he heard the
princess's light Laugh In the Hall he
didn't want to see the princess he
didn't want to see anybody
there had been something revealed when
Mr tubeau had torn that hole in his sock
and it was not the skin of a man
Tommy had caught a glimpse of
black plush Black Velvet and then had
come mrti Bose sudden explosion of Fury
good Lord did the man wear black velvet
stockings under his ordinary socks or
could he could he but here Tommy held
his fevered head in his hands
he went to Professor tato that evening
with a series of hypothetical questions
but as he did not dare confide his real
suspicions to the professor the
hypothetical answers he received served
only to confuse him the more then he
thought of Billy strange Billy was of a
good sort and his mind had a turn for
the bizarre Billy might be able to help
he couldn't get a hold of Billy for
three days and lived through the
interval in a fever of impatience but
finally they had dinner together at
Billy's apartment where his queer books
were and Tommy was able to blurt out the
whole disordered jumble of his
suspicions
Billy listened without interrupting
until Tommy was quite through then he
pulled out his pipe
but my dear man he said protestingly oh
I know I know said Tommy and waved his
hands I know I'm crazy you needn't tell
me that but I tell you the man's a cat
all the same no I don't see how he could
be but he is why hang it in the first
place everyone knows he's got a tail
even so said Billy puffing oh my dear
Tommy I don't doubt that you saw her
think that you saw everything you say
but even so he shook his head
but what about those other birds
werewolves and things said Tommy Billy
looked dubious well
well he admitted you've got me there of
course at least a tailed man is possible
and the Yarns about werewolves go back
far enough so that well I wouldn't say
there aren't or haven't been werewolves
but then I'm willing to believe more
things than most people but uh wear a
cat or a man that's a cat and a cat
that's a man honestly Tommy
if I don't get some real advice I'll go
clean off my hinge For Heaven's Sake
tell me something to do
let me think said Billy first you're
piss insurer this man is
a cat yeah and Tommy nodded violently
check and second if it doesn't hurt your
feelings Tommy you're afraid this girl
you're in love with has a streak of
salinity in her and so she's drawn to
him
oh Lord Billy if only I knew
suppose she really is too you know would
you still be keen on her I'd marry her
if she turned into a dragon every
Wednesday said Tommy fervently Billy
smiled hmm he said then the obvious
thing to do is to get rid of this
monsieur tibo
let me think
he thought about two pipes full while
Tommy sat on pins and needles and then
finally he burst out laughing what's so
darn funny said Tommy aggrievedly
nothing Tommy only I've just thought of
a stunt something so blooming crazy but
he if he is what you think he is it
might work in going to the bookcase he
took down a book
if you think you're going to quiet my
nerves by reading me a bedtime story
shut up Tommy and listen to this if you
really want to get rid of your feline
friend
what is it
book of Agnes repplers about cats listen
there is also a Scandinavian version of
the ever famous story which Sir Walter
Scott told to Washington Irving which
monk Lewis told to Shelley and witch in
one form or another we find embodied in
the folklore of every land now Tommy pay
attention
the story of The Traveler who saw within
a ruined Abby A procession of cats
lowering into a grave a little coffin
with a crown upon it filled with horror
he hastened from the spot but when he'd
reached his destination he could not
forbear telling to a friend the Wonder
he'd seen scarcely had the tail been
told when his friend's cat who laid
curled up tranquily by the fire sprang
to his feet cried out that I am the king
of cats and disappeared in a Flash up
the chimney
well said Billy shutting the book
by gum said Tommy staring by gum do you
think there's a chance
I think we're both in the booby hatch
but if you want to try it try it I'll
spring it on him the next time I see him
but listen I can't make it a ruined Abby
oh use your imagination make it Central
Park anywhere tell it as if it happened
to you seeing the funeral procession and
all that you can lead into it somehow
let's see some general line oh yes
strange isn't it how in fact so often
copies fiction why only yesterday
see
strange isn't it how fat so often copies
fiction repeated Tommy dutifully why
only yesterday I happen to be strolling
through Central Park when I saw
something very odd
I happen to be strolling through here
give me that book said Tommy I want to
learn the rest of it by heart
Mrs dingle's farewell dinner to the
famous Monsieur tibo on the occasion of
his departure for his Western tour was
look forward to what the greatest
expectations
Not only would everybody be there
including the princess vivra canarda but
Mrs Dingle a hint or if there ever was
one and let it be known that at this
dinner an announcement of a very unusual
interest to society might be made so
everyone for once was almost on time
except for Tommy he was at least 15
minutes early for he wanted to have
speech with his aunt alone
unfortunately however he had hardly
taken over his taken off his Overcoat
when she was whispering some news in his
ear so rapidly he found it difficult to
understand a word of it and you mustn't
breathe it to a soul she ended beamingly
that is not before the announcement I
think we'll have that with the salad
people never pay much attention to salad
breathe what Aunt Emily said Tommy
confused the princess darling the dear
princess and Monsieur Tebow they just
got engaged this afternoon dear things
isn't it fascinating
yeah said Tommy and he started to walk
blindly through the nearest door his
aunt restrained him not there dear not
in the library you can congratulate them
later they're just having a sweet little
moment alone in there now and she turned
away to Harry the butler leaving Tommy's
stunned but his chin came up after a
moment he wasn't beaten yet
strange isn't it how often fat copies
fiction he repeated to himself in dull
monomics and as he did he shook his fist
at the library door
Mrs Dingle was wrong as usual than cess
and Mr tibol were not in the library
they were in the conservatory as Tommy
discovered when he wandered aimlessly
past the glass doors he didn't mean to
look and after a second he turned away
but that second was enough
tibol was Seated on a chair and she was
crouched on a stool at his side while
his hands smoothly softly stroked her
black hair black cat and Siamese kitten
her face was hidden from Tommy but he
could see Tebow's face and he could hear
they were not talking but there was a
sound between them a warm and contented
sound like the murmur of giant bees in a
hollow tree a golden musical Rumble
deep-throated that came from Tebow's
lips and was answered by hers a golden
purr
Tommy found himself back in the drawing
room
shaking hands with Mrs Calderon who said
frankly she hadn't seldom seen him look
so pale
the first two courses of the dinner
passed Tommy like dreams but Mrs
dingle's Cellar was notable and in the
middle of the meat course he'd become he
had begun to come to himself he had only
one resolve now for the next few minutes
he tried desperately to break into the
conversation but Mrs Dingle was talking
and even Gabriel will have a hard time
interrupting Mrs Dingle at last though
she paused for breath and Tommy saw his
chance
speaking of that
said Tommy piercingly without knowing in
the least what he was referring to
speaking of that as I was saying said
Professor tato but Tommy would not yield
the plates were being taken away it was
time for salad speaking of that he said
again so loudly and strangely that Mrs
culveran jumped in an awkward hush fell
over the table strange isn't it how
often fact copies fiction there he was
started his voice Rose even higher why
only today I was strolling through and
word for word he repeated his lesson he
could see Tebow's eyes glowing at him as
he described the funeral he could see
the princess tense
he could not have said what he expected
might happen when he came to the end but
it was not board silence everywhere to
be followed by Mrs dingle's acrid well
Tommy is that quite all
he slumped back into his chair
and sick at heart he was a fool his last
resource had failed dimly he heard his
aunt's voice saying well then and
realized she was about to make the Fatal
announcement
but then just then Mr Tebow spoke
one moment Mrs Dingle he said with
extreme politeness and she was silent he
turned to Tommy
you are positive I suppose of what you
saw this afternoon Brooks he said in
tones of light mockery absolutely said
Tommy sullenly do you think I'd oh no no
no no no no Mr tibo waved the uh
implication aside but such a interesting
story one likes to be sure of the
details and of course you are sure quite
sure that that kind of crown you
described was on the coffin
of course said Tommy wandering but then
I'm the king of cats cried Monsieur
Tebow and a voice of thunder and even as
he cried at the house lights blinked
there was a soft thought of an explosion
that seemed muffled and cotton wool from
the minstrel gallery and the scene was
lit for a second by an obliterating and
painful burst of light that vanished in
an instant and was succeeded by heavy
blinding clouds of white pungent smoke
oh these horrid photographers came Mrs
dingle's voice in a melodious whale I
told them not to take the flashlight
picture till dinner was over and now
they've taken it just as I was nibbling
lettuce someone tittered a little
nervously someone coughed then gradually
the veils of smoke just limed and the
green and black spots in front of
Tommy's eyes died away they were
blinking at each other like people
who've just come out of a cave into
brilliant sun
even yet their eyes stung with the
fierceness of that abrupt illumination
and Tommy found it hard to make out the
faces across the table from him
Mrs Dingle took command of the
half-blinded company with her custom
Poise she Rose glass in hand and now
dear friends she said in a clear voice
I'm sure all of us are very happy to
happy to then she stopped open mouth
an expression of incredulous horror on
her features
the lifted glass began to spill its
contents on the tablecloth in a little
stream of Amber as she spoke she had
turned directly to Mr tibo's place at
the table and Mr TiVo was no longer
there
some say there was a bursting flash of
fire that disappeared up the chimney
some say it was a giant cat that leaped
through the window at a bound without
breaking the glass Professor Tata puts
it down to a mysterious chemical
disturbance operating only over Monsieur
Tebow's chair the butler who is pious
believes the devil and person flew away
with him and Mrs Dingle hesitates
between Witchcraft and a malicious
ectoplasm dematerializing on the wrong
Cosmic plane be that as it may one thing
is certain in the instant of fictive
darkness which followed the glare of the
flashlight merci Beau the great
conductor disappeared from Mortal sight
tale and all
Mrs Culver and swears he was an
international burglar and she was just
about to unmask him when he slipped away
under cover of the flashlight smoke but
no one else who sat at the historic
dinner table believes her no there are
no sound explanations but Tommy thinks
he knows and he will never be able to
pass a cat again without wondering
Mrs Tommy is quite of her husband's mind
regarding cats she was Gretchen woolwine
of Chicago for Tommy told her the whole
story and while she doesn't believe a
great deal of it there is no doubt in
her heart one per no doubt in her heart
that one person concerned in the affair
was a perfect cat doubtless it would
have been more romantic to relate how
Tommy's daring finally won him his
princess but unfortunately it would not
be voracious
for the princess bibra canarda alas is
with us no longer her nerves Shattered
by the spectacular denouement of Mrs
dingle's dinner required to see voyage
and from that Voyage she has never
returned to America
of course there are the usual stories
one hears of her a nun in a Siamese
Convent or a masked dancer in at the
legend of one hears that she has been
murdered in Patagonia or married in
trezaband trebazand but as far as can be
ascertained not one of these Gaudi
fables is the slightest basis in fact I
believe that Tommy and his heart of
hearts is quite convinced that the sea
Voyage was only a pretext and that by
some unheard of means she has managed to
join the formidable masuti Bowl wherever
in the world of the visible or the
invisible he may be
in fact that in some ruined City or
Subterranean Palace they Reign together
now king and queen of all the mysterious
Kingdom of cats
but that of course is quite impossible
that is the ending of the king of the
cats by Stephen Vincent Benet so
wonderful storytelling there
um
while you're writing comments if you
want to say anything or ask anything or
remark anything I'm going to point out
that there's some really cool features
to this story one of the ones that I
didn't of course grasp as a kid but
something that I was quite interested in
as a philosopher later on is what we
call intertextuality right so this is a
story that is kind of a reinterpretation
a redo of an older story and those older
stories are not only being referenced
within this story right the updated
version a 20th century version
but it's
the older stories are being used as AIDS
as tools within this story and it just
turns out that we've got a really smart
friend who's into things weird and he
knows this story right so that's kind of
a cool feature of this and binay is a
great author if you haven't read uh you
know some of his other stuff I'd
recommend going out there and checking
him out he was quite quite renowned in
uh early 20th century stuff but this is
this is a really interesting piece and
uh it looks like the so I as I mentioned
I encountered this within an Alfred
Hitchcock Anthology but it's actually
from a very interestingly titled uh book
of short stories which is hard to get
your hands on unfortunately called 13
o'clock stories of several worlds and
just as a side note I I love that sort
of notion of 13 o'clock you know weird
numbers my dad when he was asked about
things uh numbers he would often say
11-11 this imaginary number that doesn't
exist and you know there's also you know
great uh song by sabotage 25 hours ago
you know these these kind of strange
playing around with uh numbers opening
up a space a liminal space
that um shouldn't be there but it
actually is and this is part of the
essence of weird Supernatural stories of
fantasy of Science Fiction of of horror
of speculative fiction in general and so
this is a really fun story and I think
that you know the characters are pretty
well you know in in sort of just
outlines right sketched out for us we've
got some that are kind of um
stereotype stock characters but
um
I think this is this is quite an
interesting piece so I'd be interested
to see what the rest of you make of this
story I'm actually going to be heading
out speaking of cats in just a little
bit after we finish up here to the
almost home cat rescue where I will be
uh hanging out with the cats for an hour
or two giving them some attention some
pets some love and and care and getting
my weekly cat fix they've got a whole
new Bunch that came in uh from Texas
just a week ago so what's uh
what's on your mind about this story
anything uh that you want to bring up or
um ask about or remark
I'll say too while I'm waiting to see if
anybody's going to write something it's
it's kind of fun doing this stuff with
multiple characters you know it's been a
long time since I read stories out loud
you know I did them with my kids when
they were very young and my kids are now
in high school and college so I don't do
a lot of story reading it's kind of fun
to like take on different voices and
do the what would you call it the uh
changing tempos of the narration
and uh you know like I know where the
story is going but not all of you do as
I'm reading it unless you've actually
read it before so this is kind of a fun
feature of uh doing this so
all right well I'm not seeing any uh
questions or comments so I hope that all
of you enjoyed this and uh
I think we'll probably end here and uh
we've got some other ones coming up down
the line in the future uh the only one
that I've actually got on the calendar
right now is uh one with Ursula K Le
Guin the rule of names but we'll have
plenty of others
um oh
um
dark cats as I arrive late I have to go
back and listen to you read the story
yeah it's you know that's uh you can
listen to it as many times as you want
you know and there's a whole playlist of
the previous stories again I'm picking
out those that I
you know you can call them my favorites
they're ones that I keep going back to
over and over and over again this is one
that I've been thinking about man for
over four decades because I read it when
I was a pre-teen you know and I found it
cool back then but now knowing something
about you know people and dating and and
the the social milieu that they're
talking about it takes on an additional
resonance all right well thanks
everybody for joining me for this and I
will see you uh next time and we'll uh
we got some other great stories coming
up down the line so have a great
afternoon evening morning whatever it
happens to be where you are
to